good morning believe nation today's
message is express yourself over to you
chris adler the reason i continue to do
it I feel really actually very fortunate
to be able to continue to do it because
I've not found any other creative outlet
that compares at all and even in my
relationships with friends and my wife
and my daughter there's still no no
comparison to that form of
self-expression so it's it's me getting
to be me the way I the way I want to be
seen heard felt all of those things it's
very personal I don't think people
express themselves enough I think people
are too afraid to express themselves I
think people live in constant fear of
judgment from others that if I say this
or if I speak my mind then this person
is going to hate on me or this person's
going to judge me and you know we're
living the best version of our life and
that we're only sharing some things
about our lives that we're comfortable
sharing and that is you know nobody's
going to hate on and we're living like a
Photoshop version of our life instead of
the real version of our life and what it
does is it creates a disconnect because
you're so afraid to share something
personal and go deeper and make me
connect to you as a human being that
then you're so vanilla and then I can't
connect it's like I'm talking to
cardboard and you look at most people
who live a nine-to-five job and hate
their jobs and come home and live for
the evenings and weekends and and the
more you get stuck on that pattern the
more you're stuck on that rat wheeling
you're doing the same thing and your
expression gets shut down over and over
and over and over again by yourself by
your thoughts by your limiting beliefs
then the more it just becomes natural
normal for you and that creativity in
that spark and that expression just
slowly dies within you you think about
kids and how expressive they are and how
you know I think of Hayden my
six-year-old son is always drawing and
singing and acting and you know do we do
that as adults you like as we get older
we lose our self expression
it and I think mostly because we're
afraid of the judgment of other people
and how they're going to think if you
were to go out and do something if you
want people to connect to your business
you want people to buy from you you got
to understand that that personal
connection is one of the most important
things that you have it's the it's the
most important asset that you have as an
entrepreneur the reason why I'm going to
buy you instead of buying from big
established company is because I like
you I like your story I like that
connection and too many entrepreneurs
hide behind trying to create a
professional feel trying to look
corporate why would I would not go to
the big brand name you know price is the
same why wouldn't I go to the big brand
name with all the experience and track
record it's a company that I know when
they have the history well I want to go
with them instead of you right unless
you drop your price and then now you're
playing the low price game which you
don't want to play why would I come and
pay a premium to work with you because I
like your story because i like your
passion because i like your commitment
because i feel like you're going to take
care of me because i think that you
really have a deep understanding of this
product or service that you're selling
you just care more than that big company
so you have to make me care more why
should I care about you if you're not
expressing yourself to me and I think
too many entrepreneurs don't do that and
your websites are boring and your social
media accounts are born and your
business cards are boring and your
videos are boring everything is born
because you are too afraid to express
yourself and be who you are because
you're afraid of judgment and I'm
telling you that that is a secret
ingredient that's the magic pixie dust
that if you can unleash that expression
and creativity and inner fire then
that's going to be a magnet to attract
like-minded people to you ideal
customers to you and help you start
building the business that you want to
build and have the impact that you want
to have so the question they today is I
want to know do you feel like you are
expressing yourself in your business
leave in the comments below I'm going to
join in the discussion thank you so much
for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and i'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
events press 0
this recipe me go